Playing around with nuclear weapons in videos is fun.
There's a visceral joy in blowing things up and a horrifying fascination with
things like five balls, shockwaves, and radiation,
and what it does help put out a structure of power and perspective.
It's not the best way of understanding the real impact of a nuclear explosion.
This isn't about city stacks of TNT or about how bright an explosion is.
Nuclear weapons are about you.
So we've partnered with the red cross and red Crescent movement to explore what
would really happen if a nuclear weapon were detonated in a major city today,
not nuclear war, just one explosion.
We begin our story in the middle of downtown in a major city,
people are going to work studying for exams, uh,
lost in their thoughts and daily lives right here.
A nuclear weapon is detonators and time freezes.
The first phase of the explosion happens within less than a second in a
millisecond,
a ball of plasma hotter than the sun appears and grows in a fireball to more
than two kilometers across within this ball. Everyone is just gone.
Think of water dripped onto a very hot pan, a sizzle,
and then there's nothing. Most buildings, cars, trees,
tacky, sculptures, and people all evaporated. First,
the flash and intense tsunami of light washes over the city. In an instant.
If you happen.
To have your head pointed in the direction of the explosion,
it renders you blind for a few hours.
The heat of this light produces a thermal pals,
so energetic and hot that it just burns everything.
As far as 13 kilometers from the destination site.
What this means is that everything in an area of 500 square kilometers that is
able to burn starts burning plastic, wood fabric,
hair, and skin. If you happen to be in reach of the thermal pulse,
one moment, you're on your way to work. The next moment you're on fire.
Now, the second phase begins. It happens in a few seconds.
Most people will. Now first notice that something is wrong,
but it's already too late. For hundreds of thousands.
The flash is followed by the shockwave,
the heat and radiation of the fireball create a bubble of superheated and super
compressed air around us.
That's now expanding explosively faster than the speed of sound,
creating winds stronger than hurricanes and tornadoes.
Human infrastructure is no match for its power.
Most major buildings within a kilometer of the fireball are just ground up,
down to their base.
Only steel reinforced concrete is able to partially resist the pressure in the
surrounding parks, where it retirees feed the ducks trees,
blackened and smoldering from the heater. Second before snap like toothpicks.
If you're outside, you get tossed away like a grain of dust and a tornado.
The shockwave weakens as it travels outwards,
but still about 175 square kilometers of houses collapsed.
Like they're made of cards,
trapping tens of thousands of people who didn't have any time to react.
Gas stations, explode and fire spread throughout the rebel.
A mushroom cloud made from the remains of the fireball dust and Ash rises
kilometers into the sky in the next few minutes and casts a dark shadow over the
ruined city. This violently pause in fresh air surrounding the city,
destroying more buildings and providing an abundance of oxygen.
It depends on the city. What happens next? If there's enough,
fuel fires may turn into a firestorm that burns the rubble,
everybody trapped in it.
And people trying to flee the devastation up to 21 kilometers from the
explosion.
People just like you rush to their windows to take pictures of the mushroom
cloud, unaware that the shockwave is still coming at them about to shatter their
windows and create a blizzard of sharp glass.
The third phase begins in the coming hours and days.
We're used to the idea that help will come no matter the disaster.
This time is different.
A nuclear explosion is like every natural disaster at once.
There are hundreds of thousands or millions of people with serious injuries,
lacerations, broken bones, serious burns in the next few minutes and hours,
thousands more will die because of these injuries.
Countless people at tramped in collapsed buildings like in earthquakes,
all blinded by the flash Def from the blast wave and are unable to fly through
streets,
impossible with rubble and debris that terrified confused and
don't know what's happened to them all.
Why most likely many hospitals have been leveled along with all the other
buildings.
And most of medical professionals are either dead or injured along with everyone
else.
The survivors lucky enough to have been in Metro tunnels or standing in the
right place to be unburned.
And unhurt won't have truly escaped harm yet depending on the type of weapon
where it explodes.
And even the weather an awful black rain can begin with a radioactive Ash and
dust descending on the city covering everything and everyone,
the invisible malicious silent horror of radiation takes its turn.
Every breath carries poison to the lungs of the survivors. Over the coming days,
the people who received the highest doses of radiation exposure will die.
There will be no help,
not for hours or maybe even days civilization doesn't operate.
When there is a total breakdown of infrastructure, roads of blogs, train tracks,
walks, runways clustered with rebel, no water, no electricity,
no communication,
no stores to replenish supplies from help from surrounding cities will have a
hard time entering the disaster zone. And even if they can,
the radioactive contamination will it risky to get too close after a
nuclear attack, you're on your own.
So bit by bit people emerge from the rubble on foot contaminated with
radioactive fallout, carrying what little they may have left.
They are slow in pain traumatized, and they all need food,
water and medical treatment fast.
And the damage done by a nuclear weapon doesn't end when the fires burn out and
the smoke clears, the hospitals in the neighboring says is,
are under equipped for a disaster of this scale and overwhelmed with tens or
hundreds of thousands of patients with serious injuries in the weeks, months,
and years to come.
Many of those who survived will succumb to cancers like leukemia.
The reason no government wants you to think about all this is because there is
no serious humanitarian response possible to a nuclear explosion.
There's no way to really help the immediate victims of a nuclear attack.
This is not a hurricane wildfire or earthquake or nuclear accident.
It is all of these things at once, but worse,
no nation on earth is prepared to deal with it.
The world has changed in the past few years with world leaders, again,
explicitly and publicly threatening each other with nuclear weapons.
Many experts think the danger of a nuclear strike is higher than it has been in
decades.
Governments tell their citizens that it's good that we have nuclear weapons,
but it's bad when anyone else gets them,
that it's somehow necessary to threaten others with mass destruction to keep us
safe. But does this make you feel safe?
It only takes a small group of people with power to go crazy or rogue,
a small misstep or a simple misunderstanding to unleash a catastrophe of
unimaginable proportions exploding stuff in videos is fun,
exploding things in real life. Not so much.
That is a solution though.
Eliminating all nuclear weapons and vowing,
never to build them again in 2017,
almost two thirds of all the world's countries supported by hundreds of civil
society organizations and the international red cross and red Crescent movement
agreed to prohibit and eliminate nuclear weapons.
It's not about who has nuclear weapons and who doesn't.
The weapons themselves are the problem.
They aren't deeply immoral and an existential threat to all of us,
no matter what country you come from,
no matter what political side you find yourself on,
we need to demand that they disappear forever.
This will not happen without pressure. If you want to be part of this pressure,
there are things you personally can do to visit Notre nukes.org,
to learn more about nuclear weapons and what you can do about them.
[Inaudible].